o God it stinks no what's that smell of
lemon I'm not sure God that smell of
lemon I mean why in Earth would you need
air freshener in here with such
beautiful
airo the smell in here is crazy now let
me Sly up the window oh I guess the back
of your throat right yeah totally um is
someone going to make up the beds they
are made I've seen dog baskets uh better
old are they they put in about 5 years
ago bloody hell seriously yeah they're
definitely old
is that blood I don't think so what is
that I'm not sure it's a stain anyway
wow okay so um I'll be down in a couple
of minutes for a bite to eat sounds
great yeah what you recommend she does
the rainbow trout here what's her name
her name is Gina okay great thanks for
the update pleasure to meet you thanks
Zach
wow the view is breathtaking but the
color is depressing I mean honestly
everything's dark and gray and dingy and
the pillows look look at those how
uninviting like the dog sat on it for
the last 10 years really do
smell what is
that it's like a piece of candy stuck on
the pillow that's terrible it's almost
like they've fallen out of love for this
place and look at that big dirty stain
The Melody of Love do you hear people
shagging in the next door no you must
hear something wow holy mackerel
is that mold in there I I wouldn't be
surprised if it were
mold and where's the uh wardrobe so I
can hang my Jack wardrobe um right over
there kind of hidden behind the
microwave and moldy refrigerator Jesus
I'm feeling really nervous right now I
know that the room was really cluttered
but I didn't realize it was that bad
well at least we have a light bulb
there's a man that goes around nicking
light bulbs out of the lamps Mandy said
that he doesn't want them turned on some
guy called Jim Our Father takes light
bulbs out of the lamp he's your father
yeah mom works in the business as well
our mom kind of goes around and um helps
clean up after people's mess are they
owners as well they're investors they're
invest they're investors so your parents
bought you this place yes the moment we
saw this place I knew I had to have it
so I found every single way possible to
convince my daddy no matter what I had
to do I just had to have it I personally
think they could have gotten it for
cheaper and they probably should have
okay I can't believe you're going to be
in room 16 why cuz room 16 has a ghost
in
it this woman told me who went to room
16 she said the ghost was pulling the
blankets off her all night long and you
haven't been drinking Cherry no wow
Betty is a ghost at the Curtis house and
people do tell us that she raises a
little bit of Havoc with them she's
definitely
there I'm
16 a haunted room
my goodness
me what is that on there is that a
footprint oh man no way so what all that
big scuff yes it looks like a footprint
to me and what's that in there dead bugs
oh dear oh jeez look at this one
here I give them a list of the rooms
that are coming in there are supposed to
thoroughly check the room and what do we
do we do we have electricity in the
house I couldn't believe what Gordon
found in that room and what is
this nobody just realized or care W
beautiful
room and uh
uh I mean this is a this is a beautiful
room but why is that smell I mean
seriously it's it does smell yeah smell
[__] I mean that is horrific oh my God
it smells like
sewage we had a plumbing issue and like
someone's shot under the bed and um how
much this room goes for
$350 a night
$350 a night for room that smells of
[__] well you're kidding me we haven't
rented it though bloody hell it's been
out of use for um 4 months 4 months yeah
oh come on it has been this is crazy it
is crazy it doesn't make sense I've got
to get out of here it's things sh is
there another room yes I have room too
bloody have I didn't realize
$350 wow yes it's so empty more like a
gar in the guest room and how much is
this a night
$759
$759 wow that's incredibly expensive
what's that thing there that is actually
the jacuzzi tub in the middle of the
lounge it is in the middle of the lounge
wow when they designed the rooms they
took away all the interior walls but
without sounding stupid these are car
designers correct they are car designers
now they're putting jacuzzi in the
middle of sweet last time I checked a
living room was for sitting in not
taking a bath Jes how much do these
things cost the jacuzzi tub itself is
about $20,000 you don't take baring cars
Jesus this is crazy but who wanted all
these specially designed that is the
owner are that's Eddie that's Eddie yes
this is
crazy [__] the sports car inspired
Furniture looks cheap and isn't even
functional it's different than anything
else um different from a nice hotel room
oh I don't know about that who in Earth
want to sit here and sort of
watch the television and watch the
television it works
though the sheets how can they also
ringor when I haven't even slept in
there why is that we do them in house
when you say we what do you mean you
don't do laundry lifestyle means
everything your mouthwash it's like gas
sockets all broken and smashed down
there someone's left their dirty ones
there the plastic plants that's
outrageous $800 oh my gosh Gordon
doesn't like anything about the hotel
damn it anything else if I have any
lifestyle needs I'll call thank you
[__] hell Frozen Frozen
Frozen wow not even wrapped where are
the burgers I mean it just doesn't look
anything like a burger and when it's
processed like that and stamped and
pressed you can just tell right frozen
food wow great come with me yeah how's
the fet it's okay not the best damn I'm
sorry um Burgers a burger cooked here
locally would you expect that it be
frozen or fresh fresh the burger is not
frozen it's the patties and everything
come in frozen and they're thought out
is that you thought it out so it's not
frozen then it comes in
Frozen yeah you throw it out and that to
the your customers is not a frozen
Burger
well stay there let me just show you
[Music]
something I'm waiting for him to come
back he's going to ream me on something
oh boy here we go
MH so there's your Burgers it's a frozen
thank you now your husband said it
wasn't no what do you mean no it's it's
it's frozen of course I never said that
it wasn't it we thought it out here it
comes in Frozen yeah it's still a frozen
Burger there's no such thing as a fresh
burger at least at least here in Eastern
Washington have you seen any of this
stuff going on here do you have any idea
what's going on what's this pre-cooked
bacon pre-cooked from when it's stated
they they do it every day just about
right no they don't when was that
cooked that's not today if they did
honestly let's see what it says
10:31 we're in November the 6th now this
is insane look at that in
there don't you drain that or it just
sits there in it's blood
and in here that's a
freezer what
H what is
that what's that noise that's the
fan what a
nightmare hey Karen you've got no idea
that this is going on like
this what is that in there that's dish
water no that's french fries in there
eyes why is the water so
dirty nobody didn't change it sorry
nobody didn't change it sir but you're
cooking fries from there tonight in that
water I saw them fill up the fryer
twice it
sucks where'd you get the ham from she
bought it at the store holy crap it's a
spiral cut they cut it and put it in
here and then uh use it for side of hand
for breakfast when was the last time
this was
clean uh last year when I cleaned it
Chef last year when we cleaned the oven
we're in
November last year yes
sir I as Ken I said Ken we need to shut
down so we we we got to we got to do
maintenance look at the
mess why have you let it go like
this I didn't know that they were doing
things that were not that proper no but
let listen to me Jeff this stop
bullshitting the guy okay let's tell
them the truth here okay I asked for
some new equipment I can't get no new
equipment why not I've been here for 4
years I've been asking for new equipment
I can't work with this [__] here look
look at that I'm [__] pissed what is
this wow oh
man look at them the water's gone
slimy and you come in here once a week
yeah what is
[Music]
that oh
boy [__] hell what is
that P
colada pina colada why it's like that I
have no idea it's fested it's it's it's
off it's
[Music]
bubbling oh man that's terrible [__]
trash please
trash James trash please now peut colada
right down the drain by the bucket load
in the walk-in
fridge I mean who in the hell operates
like this Gordon this is Chef Ben's job
he's the executive chef the executive
chef and you've made him that executive
chef right sure I did how'd you feel
now what's that tuna Burger that's from
the burger yes it is oh my god seriously
bacon it's gone it's it's it's off fresh
produce on top of old produce moldy and
this one ribey ribey defrosting what is
this those are the smok grilled chicken
wings before they go onto the char grill
oh my God and what is in this one you
are kidding me so underneath in that
bucket's what cooked product cooked
chicken mhm and on top of it is what
it's raw raw chicken on top of cooked
chicken I had them for
lunch I am at a [__] loss do you know
the best way out of this is just to shut
the place
[Music]
down what a
mess Wills are stuck was just sliding on
the [__]
grease oh God that is gross Randa you
got two seconds sure just stand behind
there with you oh my goodness just no
please stand behind there I'm
I'm what is
this Mao you guys just cleaned this is
this from
today I don't even know what's back de
vindor what when was that cleaned it's
they just cleaned it two days ago they
got spilled everything there come here
I know hand on heart that is not from
yesterday that is not from yesterday
what's that up there seriously watch
your eyes watch your
eyes who cleans this
[__] who is it since I've been here no
one's cleaned it since you've been here
no one's cleaned it I appreciate your
honesty Randa yeah they say since he's
been here he's never clean clean it this
place is
disgusting and
this well I Gordon I don't come and do
this you don't I trust them that they
would clean that
they you you guys cleaned the floor the
other day didn't you we cleaned the line
the other day we sweeped the line you
said you guys took out I never said that
stop you're just trying to make excuses
yes you are aren't you embarrassed very
at least you Tau the [__] truth the
owner's in
denial that has been pulled out for
[__] months sit down you must be
shattered I'm tired I bet you are stick
of workk in me that was mad was it mad
yeah you're in the kitchen busting your
ass off working hard to serve all those
people and John you were out pring
around like a sort of actor this the
thespian thing it's an in it's not a
theater but you seen to enjoy it you
have to force yourself to like doing it
I me it's on stage for 3 hours
[Music]
being the problems at the Roosevelt are
Elementary can I just have a word with
you on your own oh
sure this place is sinking because John
refuses to take anything seriously you
love being an Entertainer don't you dare
tell me that that is hard this whole
[__] thing was put together for your
fantasy well that's kind of what this
night is it is entertainment we put on a
show you're pretending to be Sherlock
holes and upstairs we're empty you're in
the [__] financially we're in Ruins and
if you put the same amount of effort
into filling this place just one room
book tonight would have made more profit
than the whole murder mystery and all
that work that went into it I mean this
is insane and you prance around like
some [__] idiot while your wife is
slaving away in the kitchen do you have
any care in the world apart for
yourself when you get a psychology
degree oh when I get you come and tell
me what's wrong with me here we go you
obviously think you're a psychologist
denial again no I'm not in denial I just
don't know what you want it's only your
own [__] stupidity to why we're in
the [__] this far well that is probably
true so then man up and act
responsible okay I'm done with that oh
I'm done with that in
is that do that massage a bit more no
just talk to my hand you know talk to my
hand oh what a [__] idot a good 10
years old you need to grow up and stop
running away from the
truth is the start return for of the
month he looks happy bunny oh hello how
are you party one party one not party
for one uh good to see you I'm Brian is
that the same congratulations Employee
of the Month um do you get a bonus do
you got a nightstay do you get a free
dinner I'm one of the only employees
that never made the cut yet I see you
just put yourself in and what are the
owners going to say about that I'm one
of
them I'm Brian stop it yes come on hey
the other owner got their shot on there
you're the owner and you made yourself
the employee of the month
yeah are you the man with the G string
the G string reception was tell me you
you do lap dancing oh no that would
probably Kevin I see I don't know my
Booty's a little too big to do the Dan
okay I was going to say I can't wait to
see that
one I'd love to meet the other two the
chef and the lap dancer are they around
are you want to bring them out yeah all
right Kevin and Joel and I we're all
equal shareholders in this business but
it was my plan you by the hotel hello
Kevin Kevin Gordon good to see you meet
and this is Gordon Joel Joel so you're
the lap dancer there might have been
some okay right okay I'm dying to find
out I'm not I'm not a professional maybe
once in a while but okay fine I'm a wild
one when I start drinking I get a little
stripper action going on or they get a
little Rowdy and can be the most fun
that any young adult could ever dream of
soly the chef yes restaurant manager and
the lap dancer bar manager bar manager
so who's in charge all three of us no
such
thing so who runs the hotel who's in
charge of the the hotel hotel manager
job doesn't really entail
much with three owners normally there's
one that takes the reins and two other
silent none of you sound and look like
an
owner well Gordon thinks we don't look
like owners but what what's the owner
look like we bought the hotel 9 months
ago right and you guys go back a long
way just kind of met each other 15 years
ago and I'm confused whether it's the
Three Musketeers or three
stoes anyway I'm going to have a quick
bite to eat it's been a long journey I'm
excited to taste the food thank you nice
to meet you you Gordon's going to love
our food Joel works really hard at
everything he puts out everything that
comes out the window is a great product
I can't believe this hotel is owned by
three guys uh with a pink dining room
Pink's new black well it's like a girl's
bedroom Gastly Gastly um any specials on
today we had a fresh Alaskan hbit with
uh now that I'm talking to you I've
completely forgot no we had we had the
halit with a oh this is the first time I
forget specials don't worry why don't
you check with the chef all right I will
you are the ression manager right yes
and I was a server too ression manager
employe the month and owner yes all the
above employe the month I'm going to
take that plaque back can't even
remember the specials it smells like
this crap all over the floor probably
because there's crap on the
floor probably could be what does that
mean could
be my first shift here you were in the
bathroom and I think you had an accident
on the floor on the mat
oh my God I mean yeah there have been
times when I have had diarrhea but it
doesn't happen very often that um no I I
didn't realize that there was that
[Music]
problem [__] it out right um yeah love
the attire by the way thank you everyone
wears this wow how much are the outfits
about $300 $400 $300 average you know
they get their own I mean they're their
own dresses you know oh you buy your own
uniforms yes they do stop it we do well
they have them for many years and it
reminds them to not gain
weight wow so who designed the place
well uh my husband and I and whose idea
was it to buy it uh my husband so it
wasn't yours it was not my idea actually
very much against it wow uh uh why were
you against it it was very overwhelming
I had two small children but probably uh
after I lost my mind the first
year I think we started to get a hang of
it and who's Austrian are you from my
husband's half Austrian and polish right
I I'm not nearly as exotic I'm very
American right and he's the chef right
so he runs the restaurant kitchen and
you run the Inn correct and whose idea
was the violins on the table mine where
did that come from that was actually
from an estate sale down the street a
dead man's
violin why not I don't want to sit
across a table with my wife and look at
a dead man's violin well bit freaky know
I don't know what would you rather look
at when you see the Vienna her who's her
uh my wife oh your wife yes but you have
to have something to make up that white
space what would you suggest uh my wife
you're going to put her on the table
that's kind of scandalous I am so
[__] confused Dead Man's violin what
about some
flowers